and now please join me in welcoming
professor Anita Hill
[Applause]
good afternoon morning good morning
thank you thank you
of course I want to thank President
Johnson for that generous introduction
but I also want to thank her for her
leadership here at Wellesley and in yes
and in the higher education community at
large we are so grateful that she took
on the role of president of Wellesley
College three years ago to the board of
trustees Provost Shannon Shannon faculty
staff who made this commencement
ceremony possible thank you and also
thank accept my thanks for warmly
welcoming to your campus community I
have been here I feel like I've been
here for days now but only for a couple
of a few hours and I feel like I'm a
part of this but of course my big thank
you goes to the graduating class I am
humble humble humbled by your decision
to invite me to be your commencement
speaker so thank you for that you know
and I will just say this I proudly
accept the privilege of addressing the
extraordinary Wellesley College class of
2019
now this is truly the best day on
academic institutions calendar is it not
graduation day
there comes with a lot of ceremony and
celebration but that's not really why
it's so special and I'll get to that
sooner but a close second if the day you
step foot on this campus most of you
will remember it but you'll remember
perhaps more all of the things that
transpire while you were here since
arriving you've either Lee approached
the opportunity to learn to grow to
challenge your own way of thinking and
engage with others as they challenged
theirs you have proven that you are up
to the expectations placed upon you when
you got your admissions letter in short
you've graduated but there's more to it
than that many of you came to this
campus looking for an inclusive
community where you could be your
authentic selves you are looking to find
your voice and you have found both a
place where you can be yourself and
exercise your voice you have learned to
live and learn and you've also learned
to leave when struggles have tested your
resolve you reached out and you found
the resources you need
or maybe they found you maybe you even
had to explain to some people exactly
what you needed to be your true self
here on campus
either way you overcame the obstacles
that always appear when we are trying to
achieve something bigger than ourselves
and of course there were the personal
struggles and there have been references
to them before your class
speaker was soap elephant about them
Kavi and told you about the struggles
that you've had the relationships that
have soured or didn't happen at all sick
parents or grandparents your own health
issues death and financial struggles in
facing those I know that many of you did
the wise thing you saw help when you
need it or you accepted help when it was
offered to you and some plays sometimes
you had to explain exactly what help you
needed but that came from knowing who
you are knowing yourself and knowing
your value very importantly you gave
help to others when they needed help so
before I go on I just want you to do
this for me I always like to start with
thank-yous and though I want to give you
the chance to thank you to say thank you
to your classmates and to yourselves
give a hand
thank you for being there and to those
people here today teachers staff family
and friends who stood by you who
provided the structures of support that
you needed who listened to your stories
when you thought no one would here and
helped you to completely continue to
believe in yourself so that you could
succeed also give a hand
you will take away from Wellesley many
lessons be sure that you take with you a
real appreciation for what you have
experienced here a real appreciation for
the value of being an active member of a
supportive community please remember as
you leave to pass this on pass it
forward wherever you go but also
remember to give back so that future
students can enjoy an even better
experience than the one that you've had
today you may be a little uneasy because
this is a transition period the
fascinating and fantastic adventure that
you have had here is about to come to an
end and the world that you're going out
into is uncertain at best so maybe
you're a little or a lot uneasy leaving
the familiar and entering into a world
that is exciting and filled with new
possibilities but it's also downright
scary at times there are those who would
have you believe that the social
economic and political issues we face
are best resolved by pitting individuals
and groups against each other no matter
how tempting it becomes resist that
thinking this may
you
harder
[Applause]
even as we it was we've seen hate crimes
rise more hate is not the answer
no matter where you live or work or go
to school for those of you who are
continuing your education you can always
make the choice to engage in inclusion
it is a choice that you have and it is
one that I urge just as you must reject
isolationism you must also resist
cynicism in these troubling times taking
stock of the world today I know that you
are going to it sometimes be dissing
this disheartened in my work I get
discouraged but when I take the long
view I see not only how far we have to
go I also see how far we've come I never
believed that the status quo is
inevitable and you shouldn't either
nor should you believe that we have to
go back to an even more regressive time
we can move forward and we will so
typically for people when we talk about
the long view it means not focusing on
the present and keeping long term goals
in sight but if I am a descendant of a
people who just a few generations before
me had no rights I take a different
position as the first generation in my
family to attend college I and some of
you are there to give yourself away
so I start at a different place than
many when I think about the long view I
start by looking back and I start with
today with my maternal grandmother born
in 1874 in rural Texas and she by virtue
of her race and location was never
offered a public education and never
learned to read or write
she had a first child when she was 14
and went on to give birth to 13 other
children three of whom died before they
reached the age of four she had no
control of her own body whether for work
or childbearing and few resources to
devote to her children's health but my
grandmother Ida had joy in Independence
though married to a church deacon
my grandfather Henry and with
sister-in-laws who were ministers she
loved to dance and she did dance and she
boasted about dancing perhaps she saw
the prospect of a better future for her
future and maybe the dancing was a sign
of the joy of what she hoped would come
about for them perhaps she saw the
prospect when no one else did so it even
in the midst of desperate times of rank
bigotry and little hope for change my
grandmother took the long view she saw
to it that her children including my
mother born in 1911 went on to school my
mother who had her first child when she
was 16 had me when she was 44 she liked
her mother
and even though racism and sexism over
shattered our opportunities ARMA Hill my
mom scrimped and scraped to give her
children their chance to attend college
and while my father was not completely
convinced that education was really the
way out for his children he got the
picture and went along with her vision
and with her sixth grade education my
model my mother modeled lifelong
learning and in her own worry taught me
how to learn to live and to lead she
read throughout her life mostly the
Bible or her sunday-school book Reader's
Digest as well I don't even know that it
exists anymore
but she also read our local newspaper to
keep herself informed and she wrote
letters to me regularly during my
college years chronicling farm church in
family life and though she passed away
years ago when I read her letters I hear
her voice and the lessons that she was
teaching me perhaps not even knowing and
preparing me for the life that I have
today that is so vastly different from
hers but if I read her letters and I
think about both her and her mother I
wonder what all my grandmother and
mother might have said and done with
their lives about their lives had they
had the language and the liberty to
speak my mother and grandmother inspired
me to dig deeply to find the truth
because I know that there are so many
voices like theirs yet to be heard now
when I was where you are here today I
knew the world wasn't perfect wasn't
perfect for me it certainly hadn't been
perfect for my mother or my grandmother
but I believed in that moment in 1973
when I started college and in 1977 when
I graduated from college I believed we
were on the verge of monumental change I
believe that the movements of the 60s
and 70s would allow us to sprint toward
equality for all that we could end
racism and we could end sexism and
poverty could be vanquished
I was idealistic but as a beneficiary of
a hard-won battle to make this a more
inclusive country in the form of Brown
versus the Board of Education I know I
knew then the change is possible well
we still have lots of work to do and
what I once thought was a sprint to
equality has turned out not to be so I
no longer even think it is as a marathon
I now see it as a relay and I now see
that the baton that will point the way
to social justice must be passed from
generation to generation
and it must continue no matter how long
it takes us to reach our goal as our
understanding of it what true equality
means has expanded we now know that my
parents generation definition of
equality and the tactics that worked in
the 20th century must evolve to address
the challenges of the 21st century by
necessity and through knowledge the
categories that we once thought were
said have expanded discrimination based
on race gender and poverty was something
that we thought those were our touch
points and now we know that we must
address discrimination based on gender
sexual identity gender identity race
disability class age and religion
because what we know is that
inequalities are complex and they are
entrenched maybe much more than we had
imagined we need new thinking and where
gender violence is concerned the
challenges are immense
I cannot sugarcoat it the numbers speak
for themselves the National Institutes
of Health have noted that since college
entered entry 22 percent of students
reporting experience report experience
and at least one incident of sexual
assault women and non-binary students
reported the highest rates 28 percent
and 38 percent respectively although men
experience less men experience 12.5 or
excuse me 12.5 percent of men also
report sexual assault
now if these figures were attached to
any other condition we would all hear
our government saying
this is a public crisis but we must call
it it for what it is a public crisis
that needs to be addressed
and unfortunately sexual harassment
abuse and assault do not end with
college days
a recent anonymous Department of Defense
survey revealed that between 2016 and
2018 sexual harassment and assault in
our military rose by 38 percent and
according to the Equal Employment
Opportunity Commission in 2018 charges
alleging sexual harassment increased by
more than 12 percent from fiscal year
2017 and maybe the rise can be
attributed to the fact that more people
are coming forward but what we also know
is that sexual assault sexual harassment
our unreported underreported so really
we do not know exactly how many people
are being affected by this kind of
conduct and yet there are those who
would have us believe that the stories
and statistics showing the prevalence of
sexual misconduct are hoaxes they prefer
to believe in their own myths often
misogynist about the behavior and
despite the evidence sexual misconduct
deniers have friends in high places
but not not just that place one
high-profile pundit criticized campus
assault policies as the invention of
progressive feminists to promote
victimhood as a coveted status and
deniers and enablers we know from the
news include boards corporate leaders
and attorneys who engage in symbolic
compliance and refuse to reform the
cultures and structures that support
sexual harassment abuse and exploitation
in their own institutions when they know
they exist
so the problem is not just the behavior
it's the enabling that goes along with
it but but we are fortunate we outnumber
them
we are louder than they are are we and
we are ready to take them on now it's
tempting
it's tempting when you hear denial and
you hear misinformation and
disinformation to scream at your
computers or your newspapers or your
television sets but you probably don't
resort to those things I still do but
here's where we are today and this is a
this is what I want you to remember we
cannot squander the powerful voices of
the millions whose individual and
collective voices have become known as
the me to movement we cannot squander
this moment
we must use the energy and the awareness
that they have raised by bravely sharing
their stories and laying to rest the lie
that sexual misconduct is efficient the
me2 movement of 2017 was enabled by
social scientists and legal scholars and
millennial campus activists like many of
you today
it was birth birth by Toronto Berk in
2006 it has been supportive it didn't
just happen by itself it happened as a
cultural eruption of work that had been
done for decades and much of it on our
college campuses you the class of 2019
as bidden has benefited from Kimberly
Crenshaw's work educating us all about
intersectionality and because of that
work
many in the me2 movement were able to
show that skin color economic class and
gender and gender sexual identity can
shape whether women are believed and how
institutions respond to them when they
are believed and if they are believed
the me2 movement engaged men in the
campaign to end sexual violence by
allowing them the space to talk about
their own sexual abuse enforcing all of
us to abandon noxious and dangerous
notions about masculinity that serve no
one
by capturing the language and taking
commands command of a stage that had
been hostile to women's voices the
internet the movement allowed an
unprecedented public conversation to
have it from me the movement became the
bridge to what can become the policies
and practice that eradicate it that
eradicate gender violence once and for
all but our leaders must engage and
respond by passing laws to protect
against it and to prevent it from
happening and yes yes for those of you
who are attorneys out there yes we can
pass the laws to protect victims and
allow victims to become survivors we can
pass the laws to protect victims without
violating the rights of the accused and
we will and we must
so in passing the baton I want to talk
about you the class of 2019 and this is
where you come in so the movement to end
gender violence is just the start there
must be new movements that tell the
truth about our experiences and point
the way salute to solutions in many
arenas there must be a truth in science
movement your generation of scientists
must bridge the science divide that
excludes the participation of people
based on their marginalized identities
professor Evelyn Hammond has called it
out as one of the greatest threats to
equality that we face today the science
divide and I could not agree more
but I also look out and I see in the
faces of the scientists
you
the ability to take on this challenge
and have a movement and lead a movement
of your own are you up for it
now many of you have the privilege of
learning what it means to be a Marxist
feminist anti-racist at ecological
economists in professor math eyes
classroom so I know that you are ready
to lead the truth in economics movement
will you be the economist who will
develop new ways of modeling and
measuring economic contributions across
gender diversity will you be the
economist who will close the gender race
wealth gap I see you I see the future
and I see it's possible
a truth and psychology movement and
psychology was my major so I want you to
shine a light on the need for healing
individuals and fixing institutions
fixing institutions that perpetuate the
harm caused by discern spirit ease and
healing individuals who experiencing who
experience them we have not begun to tap
into our understanding of the real price
of disparities and disadvantage in our
country and that's where you come in so
my psychologist my fellow psychologists
in the room thank you for what you're
going to do in the future I also know
that we have got to do more than use the
language and the ideas that we have had
enjoyed for the last 10 15 years and you
have been schooled under I know that we
need new platforms and I know that in
this group there are some journalists
they are some computer scientists from
your generation who will provide the
platforms for sharing the experiences of
those individuals who are marginalized
whether in science or economics or
psychology or health and there are
political scientists and lawyers who
will turn those experiences into
legislation policy and legal precedents
that will retract the experiences of
those routinely ignored or didn't need
or deliberately neglect it that's what
we need whether it's an economic science
health law or any number of other areas
you have an advantage class of 29
team you have been schooled in queer
feminist critical race and
intersectional studies and theories
you've had the benefit of Professor
steady and africana studies you have the
new way of thinking that we need that
the world needs and I'm sure as
Wellesley graduates you have your own
ideas about movements that you want to
lead and I am here to support you as you
and as we together bend the arc toward
freedom
that's what it means to pass the baton
along
and I passed the baton that I do not
leave you in closing I would just say
that I'm here because in 1991 under the
glare of intense political scrutiny and
media scrutiny
I shared more of the whole of what it's
like to be a woman to be black and to be
a black woman facing sexual harassment
certainly more than my grandmother or
mother could share and more
unfortunately than women many women and
men and and all people of all genders
can share today 28 years later I have
the privilege to speak my mind freely
having found my voice my ancestor
stories remind me but that I that I must
never take it for granted and I must
never abuse it today when I look to the
future I look to you and I am reminded
by you that I must never ever give up my
voice and I will not
go class of 2019 live learn and lead
you've lived you learned yeah are you
ready to lead yes you are
and I believe you will and I look
forward to seeing where you will take us
in the future thank you
[Applause]